first up for you guys today if you had
the opportunity to role swap with
anybody in the Star Wars film franchise
who would you pick and why o bobl Frick
Wow Oh hallo guy yeah and no spoilers I
for Talk I don't want to be a little guy
that's amazing I always wanted to be
taller I think any costume in which you
can actually sit down you know kind of
like trouser jeans something as two
individuals who are just so experienced
as far as creature acting goes if
somebody else out there was trying to
get into that end of the business for
the first time what advice would you
give them one of the things I love about
the rise of Skywalker is how many
creatures are actually manipulated by
puppeteers there sometimes one puppeteer
sometimes I think six maybe more if I'm
thinking yeah maybe eight people all
coming together in a kind of dance so
you know find out about puppetry puppet
schools drama schools all that kind of
things exactly and never always go out
of your house because they never come to
get you I was come I was gone for my
front I stayed in and and I got the call
but it rarely happens so yeah you got it
you've really got to make an effort and
that terrible Network word you've got a
network and and watch movies look at
who's producing look at the credit rolls
and all that kind of thing and believe
that the creatures work better if
there's humanity coming through
manipulation so sticking with the
creature topic hottest thing right now
is baby Yoda melting hearts all over the
place so to continue doing that we were
wondering if you guys could give us a
baby Yoda's first I think babies first
if you could witness baby Yoda's first
fill in the blank what would it be
well not that obviously baby Yodas first
guess it can't be Christmas because you
don't get Christmas in Star Wars
alright a baby on his first cute
rollover when he when he's able to do
that when he's just a little and
deniro's over yeah
baby you're the first experiences snow
like he's on Kashyyyk or something and
and seeing this magic fairy stuff coming
down and see those eyes glistening with
pleasure
you just got to the heart of Christmas
with that answer - I feel like I could
see that being sent as a Christmas card
Oh what have I done
no I want it Anthony I'm curious because
in so many of these movies we've seen
c-3po kind of get picked on so when you
read the script for rise of Skywalker
and saw that finally changing for the
first time what was your first thought I
was be beyond satisfied I was overjoyed
and I was hugely grateful to Chris
Terrio and JJ for actually coming away
from the kind of habit that he's he's
been involved in all these years and
finally Threepio yes does get to be a
little more center stage if you guys
could name an unsung hero of the rise of
Skywalker who would it because we know
the wonderful ensemble we know JJ but is
there a PA a stunt person someone who
needs more time in the spotlight
oh that is that is tough well I think we
both agree stun people of which there
are so many on the set they do stuff
that generally honored and I want there
to be an Oscar or a BAFTA for them but
it's very hard apparently to sort out
who's who but they do magnificent stuff
and then they just get up and then they
do it again yeah I would say my my
handlers Alex and Heather McMullen Alex
Garnett who had to you know take care of
me when when I was like eight I need to
but whenever we take Chewbacca mask off
they blow-dry it they fixed wears and
tears and they do such a they tolerate
me and yes so we but rely on help us
because we are pretty helpless in yeah
and each creature that ever shows up on
even in the background they have helpers
and it's it's a group effort and so
those guys tirelessly work on to get
together give us the magic